remember how I said you know it is the
long way around but it's just very
simple okay all we need to do is
rephrase the integral we've got in terms
of these pieces and when it's trig these
are all the pieces that's it right it's
kind of like primary colors I guess um
where you know everything comes down to
red green and blue except for the fact
that here one of these is made of the
other two and really this is just made
of that and there's just one color I
don't know it to be weird let's give it
a go shall we seck x 13 we should write
that as one over cuz right good okay so
i can see here's my clothes piece and
here's my this is what i'm going to use
to get rid of my DX okay so I'm gonna go
straight there I don't have cause I've
got one over so I should flip it there's
cars gotten rid of I should also get rid
of I should change the variable right so
I'm going to use this i multiplied by
this DT right okay now again you've got
some convenient cancelling that's nice
so you end up with this now what can we
do with this or extension to students
partial fractions bingo this is 1 minus
t 1 plus t right so I'm going to say let
that let it go to and you proceed like
soda what do you get the a yeah but yeah
if you say let this equal this you do
have to introduce it once you introduce
this you can quote this you can quite a
bit no that's okay what do you get for a
and be people have already done the
partial fractions you get one in one ok
so that's kind of nice so now I
integrating these two things I'll put
that there now be careful because I've
gone around and I've seen this mistake a
couple of times I think you know you're
so involved in the high level Max and
stuff like that then sometimes the
little mistakes creeping and based on it
mum go under the radar right what's the
integral of 1 over 1 plus e 1 plus T
this is just what right this is just the
landing ok it's very tempting to write
well this is log of 1 minus T as well ah
but it's not why not all right this is
reverse chain rule right so you have to
account for the rim of the inside
function so this is minus mod 1 minus
team what do you got caught by that one
ok oh snap all right now for all intents
and purposes I've done all the hard work
I've done the integration now I just
have to stop back in but we can tidy
this up a little bit with our log laws
right we can't say but this is this
right I can finish tidy this up get rid
of my teas ok so let's do that
now let me say two final things to
finish this okay number one let me show
you the small gear because I there's
always sort of an equivalent right when
you have a look at this if you know the
right it's not a substitution in this
case if you know the right thing to
multiply and divide by it falls out
relatively quickly the question is why
do you x well because i know this result
and it's fairly famous because this is
such a simple integrand okay i'm going
to choose to x sec plus tan so if i have
this you think that's the worst choice
of a magical identity to x ever okay
it's like well stick with it what do you
get on the numerator when you expand you
get sec squared whom we see him a lot
don't we that should that should trigger
some alarm bells and then you get sacked
and what's really bad x okay now you
think again well what was the point of
that well the point is why is sack
squared importa wires adam is sort of a
peer so many times because it's the
derivative of tan right that's why we
see a lot and sect an surprise surprise
is the derivative sec this is f dash on
f so it's just a simple blog
now I told you there was a small gear
but honestly how many people see this
and then furthermore see this right and
so that's the equivalent of me you know
like you can you can literally make
yourself bleed by trying to turn nuts
and bolts with your bare fingers okay um
it's so short and succinct but it's very
very difficult to say